the mother of a 17 year old boy who was
stabbed to death eight years ago
is launching a campaign to tackle knife
crime and prevent young people from
carrying knives as
weapons peggy koto's son champion died
in east london in 2013
after he was stabbed 11 times in an
attack involving belts
a hammer and a knife now peggy is
calling for all 32 london boroughs
to support her initiative it's not okay
to stop
other families going through the pain
she's experienced and helped put an end
to the capital's knife crime epidemic
and penny peggy rather joins me now
peggy
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us today
tell us about champion and what happened
to him back in 2013.
the amazon champion has been stabbed in
2013 in front of the school in forest
gates
and they stabbed my son 11 times and the
boy who stabbed my son they gave him
mars lotsa
for only 14 years which is gonna is
gonna do
half years in prison so
today i'm just standing up because the
way i see i'm not only talking as a
champion's mom
i'm talking about all the murder because
i know depend losing a child
and when i've come and still going this
country i can see myself is too much
i launched the charity for my son
champion old champion charity in 2019
but since that are still meeting
most of the parents when they lost their
child enough crime
and some of them they're not even lucky
to stand up today to talk because they
cannot talk they're disabled now
they are sick they go hospital all the
time
and i cannot standing and i want to
stand today to
beg all the parents knife crime is not
only for
any people it's for all of us it's not
something it's not only for black or
white it's
everyone problem so we all need to stand
up
they said that is take a nation to raise
the child
i think that the nation is us i'm
calling from the police
the school social services
everyone to stand up about this because
eight years now since my son champion
died
but there's a lot of a lot of family
who they lost the charge in knife crimes
when my son
died i think some of the kids was five
years old
about today we can see that 13 years old
disturbing now
so if your son is five years today or
ten years today
don't say that knifecam is nothing to do
with me is is
got everything to do with you because we
have to protect the future
we have to stand up parents we are tired
is not okay campaign is to say that it's
not okay
for our kids to be killed in like
animals in the streets
it's not okay for parents to bury a
child
it's not okay to live with fear because
i know this pain
now parents we cannot even sleep no more
if your child is outside we are scared
it's not okay to live this life that
we're living now and it's not okay to
see that in the computer only to post
we need to we need to stand up the only
way we can do it when we stand all of us
together
and is take no one person i lost my son
i know the pain and if you never lost
your child
god bless you for that but it's time for
all of us to stand up
because the future it has been destroyed
our kids are the future and we need to
stand up for this feature we have to
stand up
all of us so the campaign is for all the
borrowers
all the city we have to stand up and to
do something about
it because if one person talk maybe
they're not gonna listen to us
man if all the parents stand up maybe
they will listen for us because our
girlfriend their wife they lost child
with knife crime
so is everyone problem stand up to
protect the future and i'm
i know what i'm saying this i'm visiting
the parents i'm talking
now thanks god for me but there's a lot
of parrots that cannot stand up they
cannot even talk
so i'm talking for everyone they cannot
talk i'm talking for all depends we
suffer
and this pen i'm not gonna wish it for
none of us
so please let's do something about it i
want police
school social services to stand up
because this crime is not normal no more
and i can see now even the shopping
center
this boy is disturbing in the shopping
center i can't understand it
stopping is helping the shopping center
one kids they're going to
miss their friends to do some shopping
and to have some food to eat
so now we cannot even send our kids in
the shopping center
there's no way is peace there's no way
in security
these kids they don't scare to stop they
stab everywhere they want
they don't scared about the witness we
are traumatized we are tired
we want this to finish and we cannot do
this alone the government has to hurt
the parents
we need help for the government the kids
who are down here human being
they are serious yes uk citizen we need
to fight
all this together and we are tired to
live this
life it's not okay to live where we're
living
peggy one of the areas that you campaign
on and one of the
the areas that you work in is working
with parents
to try and raise awareness of the signs
to look out for
you must have gone over and over and
over
the events leading up to that day were
there any signs
with champion that you now look back on
in hindsight that that
suggested something wasn't right that
parents should be looking out for today
no i'm i'm thinking that every parent
you know is also the job for the parents
because i'm saying
now we have to start to check our kids
in the house before they go out
because it's not good for your son to
have my son blood in your hands
and it's not good for your child to be
in prison so i'm saying that we need to
stand up
and parents we have to look after our
children we have to know them
in the house there's some there's
something they're respecting us but
outside
they get in the gang we don't even know
so we are tired to live this life
and i'm telling every parent to stand up
and i don't want your child to be a
criminal
i don't want your child to kill my son
we don't want this
so all of us let's stand up look after
your child or look after my son
so we don't want no crimes no more these
kids they are human be they know animals
and they'll be heavy like animals
when your child is touching enough to
kill someone to take his life
is it animal is evil so we don't want
this
enough is enough it's not okay no more
you want a coming together then of
parents
of the police of communities of schools
of everybody to unite to fight
this what will it take do you think
to see genuine change because knife
crime is an issue that we talk about
year after year
after year isn't it it was a a big issue
in the mayoral
election this year in london what do you
think it needs
to see genuine change
that's the that's the big problem we
have now what's the reason these kids
are not scared to go prison
if they don't scare to go prison they
can stop someone in their daylight time
in front of witness doesn't mean that
the the
the justice is not working properly i'm
witness myself the boy who stopped my
son celebrating my son death
in the prison so i say myself this
this kiss the stubby and they're
celebrating the death in the prison
and this country will living with people
they are hurt because they stop their
brother they stop their friends
and when they see someone in prison
celebrating someone else deaf
then everyone they think that prison is
a good place to be
i think that justice they have to change
the law prison have to be someone
staff when they're going there they have
to land that in prison
they cannot lose they cannot use the
fund they cannot celebrate in the
justice
because when they're celebrating their
justice doesn't mean they're laughing on
the police
and the judge so these things have to be
stopped we need a good sentence we need
a good discipline to discuss
that we need a big change i think the
government can do it i cannot make the
law
no parent can do it but we want the
government to change the law to start to
make something to be changed because we
are tired
i peggy um i hear you thank you very
much indeed for speaking with
such passion there peggy cato at knife
crime
campaigner